so uh sean already gave a good
explanation of who i am a little bit
more context about what i do
my work generally puts design
ethnography and history into
conversation to try to understand the
kinds of worlds that we're creating
through design and to propose different
kinds of alternatives and i'm really
pleased to be presenting today with my
uh colleague on this work katan williams
kate on do you want to say a word
yeah i'll just add a little bit of
context too um you know at the fun we
invest in tech companies where their
impacts on underserved communities is
woven into their business and products
so far that has been companies that
provide capital for small business
fairer alternatives to payday lending
training for home health care workers
more affordable child care mental health
support or just being able to surf the
internet without surveillance and we'll
talk a lot more about the intersections
between that venture work and my
original phd work
thank you katana the work we're
presenting today is work that we did
with our collaborator vera hovanskaya
so the starting point for what we're
talking about today is the explosion of
interest in speculative and critical
design in hci so speculative design
refers to approaches to design where we
relax the constraint of practicality so
not so much asking
what problem will this immediately solve
but to try to explore what could be
possible in design such as in this
fanciful depiction of a robot companion
for small-scale gardening
now the
worlds that are imagined by speculative
designers are not usually used to launch
new technologies instead they're
intended to question why we're building
technologies in the ways that we are and
to criticize currently dominant
strategies for design
now the explosion of work related to
this has led to a lot of questions about
whether these critical aims of
speculation actually have any kind of a
practical effect how should we
understand the relationship between
everyday practical design and critical
alternatives
we might ask does creating a speculative
alternative actually create any
meaningful change is this the right way
to think about it how can we set up more
productive kinds of relationships
between the critical work of analyzing
where technology is going and the
practical work of making new
technologies
and while these debates were happening
caitanya and i were doing research on
what seemed on the surface to be very
different topics
i was working on the long-term
consequences of rural infrastructure in
the canadian province of newfoundland
and labrador
and how developers had imagined the
future of rural communities
kitan was working with jamaican mobile
developers to understand how they were
using silicon valley style design
strategies to imagine their own futures
and their nation's future and these
cases just seemed on the surface to be
very distant from these hci concerns
but as we worked on these cases we began
to realize that what we were seeing in
our cases was vernacular forms of
speculation
and seeing speculation in the wild was
giving us a really different perspective
on how speculation actually works and
what it's both critical and practical
potentials are
and we started to realize that how
speculation was working these practices
looked pretty different from how we
typically talk about it in hci
so our goal in the work that we're
presenting today is to look beyond hci
to find new ways to think about
speculation and we're going to expand
that viewpoint on speculation in three
ways
the first is that we're going to be
thinking about speculation not in terms
of the professional practices of
speculative designers but thinking about
how a wide array of stakeholders are
acting to establish innovative futures
through technology
and this orientation of speculation
draws on literature and science and
technology studies that looks at how
people
creating science and technology
imagine and build towards new futures
the second is that instead of looking at
speculation where we typically look at
at the centers in the global north we're
going to be looking at the dynamics of
speculation in two emerging postcolonial
states
the canadian province of newfoundland
and labrador and the island state of
jamaica
and this perspective builds on critiques
that are developing within speculative
design
that argue that it's blindside blinded
by its eurocentric focus
and the third thing we're bringing to
the table is that instead of looking at
speculation in the present we're going
to be looking at analogous cases that
happened in the past and these are going
to allow us to understand better what
the dynamics of speculation are and how
they play out in the long run
so here's what i'm going to be doing
today
i'll give you a little bit of background
on speculation to help ground what we're
talking about
then i'll describe our two case studies
and how in these case studies people are
deploying speculation in new ways then
i'm going to pass the baton over to
kaiton who's going to talk about how
these understandings can inform
contemporary work to shape the futures
of black and brown communities in
jamaica and in the u.s
so let me start by describing
speculation in a little bit more detail
so in this paper when we're talking
about speculation we're moving beyond
the narrow focus within hci to refer to
a variety of practices that articulate
and try to build towards a specific a
collective or shared
possible but uncertain future
and the literature both in hci and other
literatures in social science and beyond
suggest there's two broad ways of
thinking about speculation
one way you might call constructive and
in hci typically we would just call this
doing design
and these are approaches that construct
ideas of the future with the purpose of
creating those features and so we can
see that kind of speculation in action
through the development of strategies to
explicitly imagine and develop futures
like storyboards scenarios or
prototyping
the second way you might call contesting
and so these are approaches that call
into question the futures that we
typically imagine that we are building
for and suggest new alternatives
so with nhdi that would mean critical
and speculative design
beyond hci it also describes different
artistic approaches such as afrofuturism
or feminist utopianism
now if you compare these two approaches
what you'll see is that the constructing
orientation tends to be focused on
practical problems
it generally appears to be something
that is realistically achievable
and it tends to build on the present
trajectories and technology designed to
imagine futures
these contesting approaches on the other
hand they tend to question problem
definitions
they appear fantastic and a bit
implausible
and they do so in order to question
present trajectories while also
imagining alternatives
so the question that we're looking at in
our work is
how do these understandings of
speculation change
when we focus on what's happening on the
periphery
and to study this we're going to look at
two case studies jamaica and
newfoundland and labrador
during the periods that we examine the
mid-20th century
both were recently emancipated british
ex-colonies
like many colonies
their economies were based on natural
resource extraction in newfoundland that
was the cod fishery and jamaica sugar
plantations
newfoundland and labrador was considered
a failed eco colony it had white
settlers who lived in abject poverty
jamaica on the other hand was one of the
jewels of the british empire but the
financial benefits that accrued from
that largely went to a white and brown
upper class leaving the black population
impoverished
when they left colonial status both of
these states wanted to do better they
wanted to reach industrialized status
and they both created visionary appeals
that guided that development
so what i'll do next is is describe the
speculative future visions that each
case involves
and the concrete actions that were
motivated by those visions
so first i'll talk about newfoundland
and labrador
now when newfoundland and labrador
joined canada in 1949 its people lived a
largely subsistence lifestyle in
impoverished and isolated communities
the province then embarked on a race to
catch up to become like nearby white
dominated settler states
because otherwise they were in danger of
everyone leaving through mass migration
to move to canada
the situation was pretty desperate as
newfoundland premier joey smallwood put
it it required going all out
make or break
taking a gamble
the speculative strategy that they
developed was to directly adopt the ways
of industrialization that canada and the
us were already engaged in
without concern for whether they would
actually suit the local context a small
island in the arctic stream
its government crafted a vision of a
transformed province where there would
be new industrial centers that would
replace the traditional fishing villages
steady wage factory jobs would replace
the independent fishery
and newfoundlanders could be transformed
from rural peasants
to consumers enjoying modern amenities
and this speculative vision was embodied
in government programs that tried to
transform society to match that vision
and i'll talk about two of these today
the first was a program that was called
resettlement the focus of this program
was to alter the historic conditions of
society in the province in order to
prepare it to for that hope for future
the this program shut down rural
communities and move the families who
are living in them to cities
where they were supposed to be able to
get industrialized jobs
so the way that this work was the
government analyzed which communities
should be shut down it offered subsidies
to communities willing to resettle and
when people resettled it stopped
maintaining the infrastructures for the
people who remain behind
from 1954 to 1975 about 250 communities
with 27
500 residents were resettled but the
factory jobs that were promised in
larger centers rarely materialized
when it first began people saw
resettlement as a visionary approach to
solve really complex problems that
existed in rural communities but the
more rational the program became the
more coercive it also became and
opposition began to mount against it
today most observers consider the
program to be a kind of misconceived
project that cut at the heart of
newfoundland culture
the second program was intended to jump
start industrial development and the
goal was to entice foreign management
and capital to build factories in
newfoundland and labrador and the state
pumped millions into a high visibility
factory building program that had little
oversight it was hard to find investors
for a risky venture like this so
smallwood started doing something that
he called fishing and troubled waters
he went and took advantage of the chaos
that was emerging in europe after world
war ii
to attract investors and business
experts from germany and what is now the
or was then the eastern bloc
by offering them the opportunity to
emigrate to canada through newfoundland
the lack of vetting led to immediate
problems with the factories most of the
produced factories quickly failed
um and alfred baldbonus who was shown
here ended up in prison for accepting
kickbacks
while the government knew about the deep
problems that the factories had in
public small would continue to glowingly
report on how successful and wonderful
these new industries were
because doing something different would
have undermined his core strategy for
creating this imagined industrial future
which was to convince newfoundlanders
and outside investors that it was
realistic enough to invest in
but eventually the government had to
concede that the program was a massive
failure
smallwood's strength as a leader was his
ability to
articulate these compelling visions of
the future that gave many residents hope
and enrolled them into building towards
that future in fact it said that there's
many a rural resident when they died
they had a picture of joey smallwood
placed in their coffin with them
but the end result of both of these
programs stranded those resettled rural
residents in towns that where they had
access
to neither traditional subsistence
resources
nor industrial employment
now the jamaican government also sought
transformation in their case they had
long been supplier of raw materials to
industries at the colonial center
and while slavery was abolished and they
became independent from england neither
of these things brought real economic
self-determination
so we'll describe two different
speculative visions that the government
developed to secure that
in 1972 the people's national party or
pmp
um a campaign against the jamaica labor
party who'd been in power since
independence and their campaign slogan
was better must come
it was pitched to the largely black
lower classes who hadn't benefited from
the previous decades of foreign-led
industrialization
the new prime minister michael manley
imagined a future for jamaica outside of
what he saw as the pattern of
exploitation in the region where america
was seen as a symbol of the west that
was responsible for continuously
reproducing the unjust world order of
the colonial era
driven by a commodity bom boom bomb boom
in the
1970s the new leaders increased tariffs
nationalized key industries improved
workers rights and wages and invested in
social programs to address the country's
racial disparities but things fell apart
a global recession decreased demand for
the raw materials that were needed as
the economic engines to drive that
vision
a new government then proposed that the
future could be found within not against
the western mode of development and a
big part of this was to encourage
economic liberalization and direct
foreign investment
through the promotion of free trade or
special economic signs so those are
areas where foreign companies could
operate while receiving incentives and
reducing taxes
and these uh these sites found a
speculative apex
when they were remade as sites for
informatics work and a business
processing process outsourcing industry
so jamaican planners envisioned a mutual
benefit their trainable and
english-speaking people
would combine with the region's
geographic and cultural proximity to the
us
to allow for a local near-shoring
industry that would grow alongside the
efficiency demands of american business
and they imagined that this transfer of
technology and know-how from foreign
firms would catalyze a local tech
industry and that would remake jamaica
for a digital world
but while those corporations poured raw
data into jamaica they weren't quite as
enthusiastic to distribute the wealth
and expertise that emerged from
processing it
and those same networking technologies
that made it possible
for business to come and offshore in
jamaica also let them move away quickly
to other places that were cheaper when
they came online
so what can we learn from these two
cases about how speculation is pursued
on the periphery
now as a reminder we saw that research
on speculation at the center contrasts
two different modes of speculation
the first mode is constructive it's
practically oriented it dreams big
and it's focused on actually
establishing a new future
the second contesting mode dreams even
bigger
it purposely expands our visions beyond
what might seem likely or possible
with the goal of destabilizing
assumptions about whether these are
necessary or desirable features and to
suggest that other things might be
possible
in our cases what we see is a mix of
these two different modes
speculation was simultaneously audacious
and pragmatic
it was tied to pressing problems that
urgently needed resolutions
newfoundland and labrador faced a
looming mass out migration
and jamaica addressed the historic
impoverishment of much of its workforce
so newfoundland and labrador envisioned
an industrial wonderland on a hard to
access island in the cold waters of the
north atlantic
while jamaica pitched the neo-liberal
tropical paradise with open economies
and friendly natives that would tap into
the capital and expertise of faraway
firms
our core argument is that in building
visions of their future these projects
on the periphery had to work together
both of these modes of speculation
constructive and contesting
in the constructive mode their goal was
to create a coherent vision of this
future social situation
that would motivate people to engage in
action in the present that action could
establish that imagined future by
providing a sense of certainty
within the very real challenge of
creating economic prosperity for small
postcolonial states that were very aware
of their marginal roles in the world
stage
in the contesting mode
these projects envisioned alternatives
to a status quo that would leave them
forever stuck in developing status
these visions of themselves as
established economic powers or even as
states with full agency questioned
established realities and power
structures
but constructing and contesting futures
are very different modes of speculation
conflicts between them had to be worked
out pragmatically on the ground
so what i'll do next is describe three
ways these conflicts were actually
worked out in practice
the first example is about tensions that
arise between fantastic visions and
pragmatic problems
so in critical and speculative design
speculation is often talked about as
something that's different from and
potentially opposed to direct and
instrumental problem solving so the
choice of speculation
is often framed as being not
particularly concerned with solving the
practical problems of the present
instead focusing on alternative
viewpoints of what the future could hold
and our cases are not like that
in both jamaica and newfoundland and
labrador the states face very pressing
problems but in the case of newfoundland
the futures that were imagined were so
speculative that they seemed fictional
even to the people who were living there
at the time
so why did they do this
one reason that they built on an
unlikely future was because they didn't
have much choice
in post-colonial newfoundland and
labrador there was no clear route to a
prosperous future except for leaving the
province so unlikely futures were the
only way forward
and that meant that people were okay
with exploring possibilities that
otherwise would just seem impossible
and a similar dynamic characterizes
jamaican speculation
when the initial ambitious but plausible
futures were derailed
and as mounting national debt reduced
the room to maneuver planets planners
shifted
to ever more unlikely imaginings of a
road to upskilled prosperity through
attracting offshore capital
in speculative design speculation is
explicitly used to break out of the
limits placed by pragmatic concerns
but when speculation is necessary for
survival it becomes very difficult to
discern where the line is between what
is speculative and what is practical in
fact speculation is used as a pragmatic
tool
pragmatically
it enrolls many different people into
what would otherwise be difficult or
even impossible future making exercises
so in newfoundland and labrador this
kept people from out-migrating and
convinced them to stay in newfoundland
and build a future there
in jamaica
uh it enrolled other third world nations
into that jamaican project and the
common projects of liberation
and in both states those efforts were
used to enroll external economic actors
such as refugee east block investors
multinational firms jamaican expatriates
to invest in local economic activities
now on the periphery
issues like this how do you enroll
people into your project become
particularly urgent because they're tied
to the very desperate conditions that
speculation has to address so smallwood
for one had a very serious problem to
address which was that it was expected
that most of his province's population
was going to migrate to mainland canada
and when speculation proceeds from this
kind of desperation
arguably the vision has to appear in
proportion
to the scale of the problem that it's
addressing
the very desperateness of the practical
situation requires a truly fantastical
vision
to counterbalance it and to create that
effective pull
our second example focuses on tensions
between fiction and reality and future
visions
so we just unpacked why these states
developed fantastic visions but creating
a fantastic vision also creates
practical problems because they create a
profound gap between the reality of the
lives that people are living and the
future that they were expected to
believe in
and speculative design gaps like this
are deliberately exaggerated in order to
induce yours to question the futures
that are being proposed so if a
future is obviously fictional it calls
attention to the fact that it's been
constructed
but how could these states harness
fantastical visions while making them
feel like they were still plausible
enough for people to really invest in
and one strategy that these states used
was to link their own fictions
to specific coherent non-fictional
realities those that existed in
neighboring states
so in newfoundland and labrador
the power of these images of an
industrial future
was fed by its citizens growing
awareness of north american standards of
living and their comparative poverty
confederation with canada meant that
they began to expect that similar
standards would exist in their own
future
jamaica first rejected this idea of
copying realities from the center and
instead created an ambitious but
plausible future
in collaboration with its peripheral
neighbors
but when those plans became untenable
and imagined features became more
improbable
it instead grounded its own visions in
an industrial trajectory
that built on the capitalist expansions
of nearby us and the imaginations that
people had about the role that
peripheral locations could play in them
so in both newfoundland and labrador and
in post-1970s jamaica
the state actors has made their
audacious visions seem legitimate in the
face of dire straits
by linking those to reality
by linking the realities in other places
to fictions at home
and the center's reality in these cases
motivated and underwrote the periphery's
aspirational fiction
the third example that i'll discuss
involves a tension between conservative
notions of future making and their
emancipatory goals
in science and technology studies
distinctions are drawn between forms of
speculation that reinforce current
narratives of technological progress
and so-called emancipatory approaches
that question those narratives and
present alternatives
and that distinction lines up to some
degree with the designers done in rabies
distinction between affirmative design
which reinforces how things are now
and critical design which rejects how
things are now as being the only
possibility
and in these cases we see projects that
are simultaneously conservative and
emancipatory
in our cases on the periphery the most
obviously emancipatory future making was
that of manly and the pnp and 1970s
while their imagination of black and
national power contradicted the
expression expectations of the us and
most of the world it wasn't actually
speculative in the sense of being
apparently unlikely
but when that didn't work and without
other viable alternatives the jamaican
government changed course to a
conservative strategy that adopted
logic's development that arose from the
center
in a similar vein the smallwood
government took an industrial future as
existed in canada and the u.s as a
necessary given if the province were
going to survive
and that industrialization plan was the
only way it could imagine to reach that
future
so while these projects were certainly
speculative they were simultaneously
conservative and that they constructed
features along given known lines
but there's something inherently
emancipatory even about these projects
that adopted development strategies from
other places
they were emancipatory because they
imagined that these industrial and
liberal powerhouses could exist not just
at the centers but also right where they
were
x colonies on the edge of the atlantic
even and maybe especially when they were
being the most affirmative
these projects contortions and the
failures that they led to made clear
the structural difficulty
of peripheral places
fitting into these definitions of global
economic success
what's scandalous in these cases is that
the governments of jamaica and
newfoundland and labrador
took these ideologies of industrial
liberal development seriously
they didn't accept the unspoken truth
that these ideologies were only ever
supposed to work for those at the center
of the global order
for example critics commonly say that
the problem that smallwood ran into was
that he actually believed that the
centralized model of industrial
development could also work in the
periphery
however unintentionally these projects
demonstrate how the game is rigged
so far we've been talking about
speculation in terms of mid-century
national development but what can these
considerations tell us about the
contemporary development of technology
right here in silicon valley
so in hci we often think of these two
approaches as conflicting either you're
constructing futures or you're
contesting them
but in our cases we see constructive and
contesting approaches as deeply
intertwined and the reason this happens
on the periphery
is related to questions about who is the
author of the future
if you are not the one who is supposed
to be deciding what the future is going
to be
then even while you construct a future
you also
maybe even accidentally
need to contest
so next i'm going to pass the baton to
kathon to reflect on how this dynamic
plays out in contemporary work to
construct features with black and brown
communities in jamaica and in the u.s
all right great
so this this question
this question of not just authorship but
also legitimacy
for designers on the world's margin it's
something i care a lot about i'd like to
share a few more details as we were set
up from contemporary context that sort
of teased these concepts out further
that we've discussed here and in this
historical paper and then i'll hand back
to people to close
um
these are contexts that might feel more
familiar to itse than the work of state
planners and our historical examples
but they're absolutely driven through by
the same tensions we identified
what these cases show is that if you're
not considered to be a natural author
contesting and constructing might be
inescapably tied together
i think this is most vivid in the work
that i've been doing with startups over
the last seven to eight years first in
jamaica and now in the us
and you know the jamaican historical
case in our speculation paper was part
of how i try to contextualize
this contemporary ethnographic work i
had done with tech entrepreneurs in 2014
during this high intensity period in the
island startup scene where there's this
national tech hub that was being
launched in partnership with the world
bank called startup jamaica there were
these tech meetups hackathons and pitch
sessions that were happening frequently
across the island
and the question that i want what i
wanted to know was what was it like to
navigate like a technical and also like
a personal transformation
against the background of an intense
period of nation building and striving
how were these design methods that these
startups were using and the ideologies
behind them that were largely derived
from a real silicon valley or imagine
silicon valley how were they being
folded into these long-running projects
that jamaicans have been undertaking
to uplift themselves to remake
themselves to elevate the nation
and as phoebe alluded to earlier to
really understand what was happening in
the design work that manifested on the
screen we have to dive into this set of
cultural political social and economic
currents that extend far beyond their
computers and historical work on
previous national visions was a critical
way of understanding what was happening
in the present
so to return in the 80s and 90s in the
case we covered in the paper jamaica had
attempted to capitalize on what was a
new era for technology and business this
era was marked by the satellites new
tech for optical character recognition
informatics for data capture analysis
but this was paired with this voracious
need for digitization in the us that was
related to new corporate practices for
offshoring and outsourcing
that industry never went away
but it wasn't the innovation catalyst
that state planners had hoped for it
didn't deliver on this immense support
emancipatory potential to move from
lower to higher forms of capital
so by 2014 jamaica had this new national
development plan called vision 2030
and the startups and the technical hubs
around them were a new possibility for
national change during a time of high
national debt and high youth
unemployment
so this is a similar premise about a
shifting error in technology and
business that we saw in the 1980s but
this era more contemporary is marked by
cheap globally accessible infrastructure
through which people can learn develop
and deploy software
and now large international audience
that's accessible because of mobile
phones and the internet
you can deliver software as a service
and that's the norm rather than thinking
about shrink wrapping in plastic and
moving it physically
and now tech companies are the top tier
of the stock market certainly in the us
so the the top line seems much larger
and when i returned to
california from jamaica finished my
dissertation and then eventually
transitioned to work in this venture
fund that is focused on uplifting
low-income black and brown communities
in the us i saw many of the same
dynamics the same dreams and the same
relationship between a center and a
periphery
i know this can seem odd i mean yes the
black and brown founders in the u.s have
access to much more resources than the
jamaican entrepreneurs i worked with had
and venture funds like mine don't even
exist in jamaica at all
but at the time at the same time there
continues to be this large disparity in
who gets funded in venture capital in
america only around two percent of
funding goes to black or hispanic
funding teams funding teams so being
black in america can feel like you're
redlined within a periphery culturally
economically and sometimes even
geographically
in our experience this drives similar
vernacular forms of speculative
practices as we cover in the paper also
marked by the similar interplay between
fantastic and pragmatic
real and fictional conservative and
emancipatory and in particular they
highlight how they're always
constructing and contesting when you're
not seen as this natural author of tech
this interweaving feels inescapable
on one hand if you're a black tech
entrepreneur in the americas you have an
uncomfortable alliance with capitalism
it's an unequal system
it's rooted in the historical and
ongoing marginalization of people who
look like you
but on the other hand you're imagining
that the system will finally work to
your benefit
to do that you're squarely in
constructing mode you're seeing largely
within the range of possibilities that
are driven by the expectations and the
imaginations of the mainstream of
silicon valley that includes what kind
of technologies are acceptable to build
what business models are profitable how
fast you could grow how big you can get
but at the same time you are contesting
one just implicitly just by who you are
by your very presence in an
underrepresented field
but also explicitly you're claiming that
specific audiences often underserved
communities of color should matter to
people who haven't considered them
before
and you're challenging ideas of who can
bring technologies to market and that
you too can bring speculated futures
into reality even though you're outside
the center you're outside of silicon
valley
and you're pointing to opportunities
that your peripheral position gives you
insight into yet are hidden or
misunderstood
by others
and so even as a venture fund with the
impact mission we too are deeply within
this form of speculative practice
my work as a funder now feels like a
connection from that work as a
researcher it's under the umbrella of
this kind of constructive speculation
that on one hand is intended to create
futures that are clearly friendly for
global finance and techno science you
know positive impact and community is a
requirement of every investment we make
but we've chosen to be in a system where
we're judged by mainstream financial
returns
at the same time we're currently using
the system of venture capital as this
critical design media
for for lots of reasons venture capital
has animated the interest of a lot of
people outside of tech or finance
and we're using that platform that is
that's been given to us by venture
capital to shout questions about
america's historical and ongoing
marginalization of black and brown
people
we're asking how the world could be
different if they were placed at the
center
so to wrap up when you're not considered
a natural author these experiences have
shown us that a lot of the criticality
is just positing that you can create
technology regular technology it's in
imagining yourself and your community as
a place of technology production and
creativity in pushing back implicitly
and explicitly against the role that the
world has imagined for you
it's in innovations that often serve as
provocations they appear fantastic to
some people
but they're blindingly obviously
necessary to others and they're deeply
connected to everyday realities people
and solutions that the mainstream has
not
mobilized to support and i'll stop there
feedback team
okay having too many technical
difficulties to bring my slides back up
but let me nevertheless just wrap up
by saying
uh to that within hci
we often consider constructing and to
testing features to be at odds with one
another
and what we've tried to demonstrate in
this talk is that constructing and
contesting features can
and often does exist in a kind of
complex dynamic especially on the
periphery so what you saw in our cases
was that they were focused on practical
problems
but in order to address them they often
had to question how the problem was
defined in the first place
in order to gain traction they had to
reach into the fantastical since the
status quo wasn't working
so they had to reach into the
fantastical
but they find strategies to make that
fantastical appear plausible
that's raw on realities in other places
and they build on known trajectories for
technology technologically infused
development
but to be willing to draw on those
trajectories in places where they're not
supposed to happen can itself be a
critical move
so what it comes down to is that
constructing and contesting are deeply
intertwined
thank you i look forward to your
questions
are there any questions
online okay
great then i guess phoebe and katon uh
you can
is it possible for you to see the raised
hands okay so if you call on them we'll
unmute them yeah
great so i see that that's a question
hi um just make sure i got this out um
i do not speak for the bank in any way
shape or form um
that said um it seems a little bit
unclear to me how much
agency we leave to these peripheries
if we allow the kind of subjugation
argument to rest in these very hard to
falsify frameworks
um but for example if you connect some
of the empirical dots that's
you were offered right um there was uh
kind of like an effort to emancipate
yes if you don't have the correct ideals
or the new ideals it's going to be very
hard but
people also choose to use google and not
a plausible alternative say built in
jamaica and my understanding is even in
the us the colonization of language is
criticized by the american government
itself right that
google has this kind of you know
almost yeah the corruption in
newfoundland seems to play a role when
we prefer to kind of like
maybe they also prefer to copy the
governance structures
in
of their neighbors because they couldn't
stamp out corruption the way they did
things
um i was wondering if you could comment
a little bit about uh how do you see
this this kind of uh uh
issue of agency and and that you copy
not just because
you you don't think they're you don't
believe in new alternatives but you copy
because they seem pragmatically useful
to you
and it might not be as necessarily
coercive but just
it's very hard to put together good
regulation
you know it's it's complex i mean
yeah thank you
yeah a great question really complicated
um difficult to thoroughly answer but
the starting point i would say is that
people definitely do have agency there's
no doubt they have agency we see them
have agency and take advantage of that
agency in these case studies so
um
i don't subscribe to the idea that
there's kind of a uh
a system that's set up
purposefully to kind of explicitly
marginalize these people by some kind of
cabal who's trying to control them
that is definitely not what is happening
in these cases people are kind of
grabbing on to the opportunities of the
future that they can find and they're
showing an actually an incredible amount
of creativity and how they're thinking
about it and how they're going about it
because um uh even if though i'm i'm
quite critical of how planners were
imagining modernization in newfoundland
in the 1950s and i see all the bad
outcomes that came from it they were
dealing with an incredibly difficult
problem
and there it was really hard to find
other ways and now with the benefit of
hindsight you can start imagining how
they might have done it differently but
at the time they were definitely doing
the best that they could right
so the structural question is um
uh around uh
i guess part of the question is does it
completely shut down or foreclose
possibilities
or does it simply constrain them in ways
that require people to be inventive
and my i think the answer for me is it
does a little bit of both and what you
see is that if you look at it globally
world power structures do not stay
stable
you can see for example the the example
i think about a lot is the rise of the
hardware silicon valley quote unquote in
uh
and sorry about that
in shenzhen china that's something where
power has definitely shifted so power
does not stay stable it is possible to
move it's just much more difficult in
some places than in others
uh caitanya did you want to say anything
about that or shall we move to the next
question
really quickly agree about constraints
and agency i think
um in particular in the jamaican case
you know what's happening in the 70s and
80s there is like a lot of contestation
locally about what the path is it wasn't
you know forced to move
the the the sort of like the drive to
what happened in the 80s was already
happening in the 70s um there was an
opposition party as phoebe explained
there's sort of like warring fractions
about what jamaica's path to growth
should be so it is in some way over
determined by a set of constraints but
it's not as simple as that
i see that as a question
yes
um thank you um that i that made me
think about so many things even about my
own experience in academia
but um i wanted to ask a question maybe
related to the previous question um i i
feel like there is some kind of a
dynamic that i wasn't sure if it was
explicitly pointed at and i'm still
trying to articulate it but it feels
like the person making the decision and
doing the speculation
and those who are um
given
that vision
might be two different entities and i
was wondering if if that makes any sense
to you and if you think that everyone is
contesting and constructing at the same
time or are they different like is the
person imagining actually just
constructing
um and those that are that division are
contesting or like
i don't know does that does that make
any sense
that makes a lot of sense okay john do
you want to start on that one
yeah i mean i mean broadly i think in
the case
of
in 1980s in jamaica you have
a set of national plans that are
informed from say in case of jamaica
requirements of structural adjustment
that i think of as almost purely
constructive and you have a set of local
actors that are trying to make the best
of that that i think through the sort of
like standard political parliamentary
process are a mix of
construction and contestion making the
best of sort of like outside boundaries
that are forced upon them by
multinational agencies
yeah in the case of newfoundland on
labrador there's a
theoretical concept i find really
helpful for thinking about this that's
used locally which is the term nested
peripheries so the idea is you've got
newfoundland and labrador is relatively
unpowerful within canada within
newfoundland and labrador you've got the
provincial government and then you've
got the communities that are spread out
across the island and through labrador
then within those communities you've got
communities that are more powerful and
less powerful and often these these
divisions i would say that come from the
provisional government are contesting
what's happening in canada
but at the same time there are going to
be contestations of those visions that
are coming from the people who are kind
of lower down on the pecking order
so yeah it's complicated so yes you
definitely understood that correctly
see you have a question
hi yeah thank you for the interesting
talk i was wondering um
regarding the line if you are not the
natural author of the future you must
contest while you construct i was
wondering if you could expand on like
who
is the natural author and then like how
do you contest
yeah so good questions i mean what i
would say my my answer is very case
specific in our case it was very clear
that um
newfoundland and labrador was considered
within the british empire to be a failed
colony it actually returned to colonial
status after having been an independent
nation because it was considered to have
failed
and canada was very clearly placed the
canadian federal government was placed
as the people who knew the right way to
be
so that was kind of the way that the
whole thing had been set up for them
from the beginning
um
and how do you contest well that's very
challenging i mean the way that
smallwood contested was he created the
speculative vision he used that
speculative vision to
um
gather an awful lot of um
affective investment from his populace
get financial investment he got a lot of
financial investment from the federal
government of canada and to use that to
gather the resources to try to make a
change
so leveraging that vision i suppose
and you know under on the natural part
um obviously that's a little facetious
but
yeah a question i ask is that what do
people think of when they think of
jamaica uh it's certainly not um that
scene that phoebe showed with people at
their desks and cubicle farm you think
of tourism if you think about marley
maybe you think of
sprinters and the olympics but we don't
imagine it and the caribbean writ large
as a place of technology and that's a
that's a media framing
so it's a historical colonial
relationship framing and that's why a
lot of the work
of the entrepreneurs that i followed is
about like showing up on certain stages
and explicitly correcting
particular narratives by emphasizing
certain points and
maybe even building forms of technology
that they may not have chosen to build
otherwise but they know that they need
to challenge this idea that they can
create technology so that the
technologies that they create seem to
often have to be more audacious to
establish themselves as authors
hi um um
thank you for that talk um nice to see
you both um
i won i was struck by a phrase you used
at the beginning of the talk which was
vernacular forms of spectacular design
and i really like that idea of the
tension there that you're framing
between the constructing futures and the
contesting futures because i think that
notion of the vernacular form
of these critical design approaches
uh kind of opens up the the question
space in a really interesting way
and
the question i had for you was whether
they're
do we just end up with this mundanity in
which these contesting futures just open
up the
uh the sort of the overton window of
possibility for the for the for the
constructing futures that is you know
you come up with something really wacky
and then that just makes the the sort of
mundane offering uh all the more
and increases the possibility of
something coming the mundane or do we
manage to retain something of that
critical nature of the the contested
futures when they actually gets executed
and i guess there's probably a question
for catered more than
than thieves but but obviously both of
you probably have thoughtful comments
yes
i think of what is in the context of um
venture capital you know our our forum
our firm invests
with the so ultimate beneficiaries being
the communities
but
you know often that means that you know
90 or so of our founders are
representative of those communities
because they are the ones with the lived
experience that understand those places
that's an argument where we push it for
some time i think the context of venture
capital the consequences of thinking
almost explicitly about community is
sort of like
almost against the thesis of venture
capital and the kinds of returns that
you want to get to so an accommodation
you end up with is funding more diverse
founders even though they may have more
constructing types of visions and
contesting visions but
i think that is still an advancement
right so i do think to your point that
is exactly what is happening like you're
opening the overturned window in the
context of jamaica you see these failed
national plans decade by decade but they
are slowly incrementally increasing the
window and changing the vision of how we
think of jamaica and what is possible to
come from a place so in the context of
venture capital having uh black and
brown founders who've had large exits
and build large companies changes the
evaluation for founders who are doing
community oriented companies hmm
thank you that's really useful as a
framing
we have two minutes left but i seek as
another question
oh yeah i just i didn't want to just
criticize it i i really like the work so
so i'm
putting my speculative design hat here
the kind of the global regulation and
imagine realities
are we arguing here to make some of
these uh kind of essential
technologies if you will the googles of
the world is global public utilities
because otherwise we're kind of
privatizing too much of the space for
the periphery to even imagine itself as
something
different there's just basically it's
almost like this coercive effort because
there is no alternative that is credible
because of i don't know network
externalities whatever economic job you
want to use is that is that what we're
thinking here yeah thank you
another great question without an easy
answer
um i would be inclined and i'd be
curious to hear if katana agrees i would
be inclined to
be somewhat skeptical but from these
cases and generally that moving it to
the public sphere would necessarily do
away with the power differences
um the the the
cases we both look at are actually cases
where the governments were deeply
involved
and um
there's a lot of winners and losers
getting chosen by the government in ways
that aren't necessarily democratic and
that don't necessarily undo those kind
of the the the power problems that you
were talking about
um i would say uh pro on the on the flip
side i'd say having many different
approaches to creating futures is
probably better than just having one
approach to creating different futures
so if the public investment model is one
alternative then i would like to see
many alternatives to to create more
possible openings
i unmuted but i didn't have anything to
add
okay
thank you sean are you there should i
pass back to you yeah i think let's
thank phoebe and katon for that great
talk and wonderful discussion so thanks
so much